we all have intrusive thoughts from time
to time and many of us for example will
check whether we have our airplane
ticket before going to the airport more
than once that is an OCD to have OCD you
have to have obsessions and compulsions
that impair your life and are highly
distressing and a rule a sort of
rulebook would be maybe at least an hour
a day but most of the patients that I
work with will obsess and compulsive a
and really their life can be ruined I
have some patients who come to me and
say look I know I don't need to be
washing my hands like this but I can't
stop and I have other patients who are
really not sure really not sure I mean
they really believe that if they don't
wash maybe they'll actually get ill so
there's that sort of range of insight
it's also true that someone in my office
can say you know I know the subways safe
and I could touch that pole but if I
walk onto the subway with them doing an
exposure and ask them to touch the pole
in front of me they lose their ability
to have to you know remember that this
isn't going to kill them so obsessive
compulsive disorder is a disorder where
patients have obsessions and compulsions
and obsessions are intrusive thoughts
images or urges that they find very
distressing and are very repetitive and
compulsions are behavioral acts or
mental acts things they do in their head
over and over again to try to reduce the
distress that obsessions caused or to
follow specific rules so while all
patients with OCD have obsessions and
compulsions the content of the
obsessions and compulsions can really
vary so one type of patient can have
intrusive concerns about contamination
and maybe washing doing elaborate
washing rituals a different patient
might have intrusive thoughts about
harming either other people or harm
befallen themselves and they for example
might have rituals of checking to make
sure that the harm
didn't happen yet another type of OCD
patient might have what's called just so
OCD where everything has to be either
arranged or ordered in a certain way or
they have to actually do things in a
certain way and they may be repeating
and rearranging and organizing all day
long and finally there's a group of
people who have what we call intrusive
taboo thoughts it can be about sex or
religion or violence and often these are
images that they have and again they
might have elaborate rituals to reassure
themselves that they actually didn't
actually commit any of these acts now
it's not like OCD patients only have one
you know often OCD patients have more
than one of these types of obsessions
and compulsions together but that's sort
of a flavor so there's a sort of simple
version right fear of contamination with
washing rituals but OCD can get really
you know sort of far out so for example
I once worked with someone who
California was contaminated and so what
it meant was she couldn't have anything
in her apartment that had the name
California in it when may if a envelope
had once arrived to her mailbox that had
California on it her mailbox then became
contaminated or for example intrusive
harm befallen you know I've had patients
who worry that maybe they've driven over
someone as they drive and so they can't
make it to work because they're going
around and around the intersection to
make sure that they haven't run someone
over but the harm can also be very very
abstract not as concrete as that but
very very abstract so you know there are
many many many versions of OCD
what we know is that when you do brain
imaging studies of people with OCD and
you compare their brain to the brain of
people who don't have OCD that there is
a hyperactive circuit in the brain
that's been linked to OCD and that
hyperactivity in that circuit has been
confirmed through animal studies now we
don't think it's only that circuit we
think there are other circuits that are
likely involved as well but there's a
real clear neuroscience of this behavior
of obsessions and compulsions how the
brain get that way and here we know less
about that what we do know is that in
some families but not in all families
OCD seems to run in those families and
certain genetic studies suggest that
there is a familial contribution to OCD
but again not in all cases but exactly
how that particular brain circuit went
awry in that particular patient we don't
know that we're working on it we don't
know yet